Captain America, Iron Man, Thor, Hulk, Black
Widow, and Hawkeye.
These six heroes have led the charge within
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for more than
ten years and twice as many movies.
And with Avengers Endgame bringing them all
together again, it seems fitting to go over
each of their story arcs leading up to this
epic crescendo.
Of course, trying to watch every MCU movie
in a row is a nearly two-day-long endeavor
at this point, so we've gone ahead and condensed
each original Avenger's story for you: here's
how each Avenger got to Endgame.
The MCU got its start when Iron Man arrived
in theaters in 2008.
Robert Downey Jr.'s impressive performance
introduced us to a narcissistic Tony Stark
who was used to having things his own way…
until he got kidnapped by the Ten Rings and
had to build his first Iron Man suit to regain
his freedom.
From there he etched his name into the Marvel
hall of fame by helping stop threats such
as Iron Monger, Whiplash, the Chitauri invasion
of New York, Aldrich Killian, and Ultron.
But Stark's true arc always focused on his
own inner struggle as he came to grips with
who he was without his "tricks and toys."
Once just a billionaire playboy, the man has
slowly evolved into a thoughtful, caring hero.
His loyalty to Pepper Potts and father figure
status to Peter Parker are excellent examples
of how he's matured over time.
And then there's the role he's played in setting
the stage for the Thanos epic.
His prophetic vision in Age of Ultron gave
him a unique sense of urgency that continued
to fuel him as he tried to prepare for the
Mad Titan's impending arrival.
Thanos clearly had an affinity with the Iron
Avenger, too, as shown through his assertion
that they were both "cursed with knowledge"
during Infinity War, leaving a potential showdown
between the two in Endgame a positively tantalizing
prospect.
While Hulk has been a bit of an enigma throughout
the MCU thus far, his story can basically
be broken down into three eras.
First, we have his solo film, which came out
after Iron Man.
It showcased Bruce Banner, then played by
Edward Norton, already on the run, in love
with Betty Ross, and relentlessly pursued
by her father.
The film ended with Banner having more or
less come to terms with "the Other Guy."
The second era opened up when Mark Ruffalo
picked up the mantle in Avengers.
Banner and the Green Machine seemed to have
taken a few steps back at that point, as neither
wanted to surrender control to the other.
The duo continued to help the Avengers for
a while afterward, and sparks even began to
fly between Banner and Black Widow in Age
of Ultron.
But it all came to a screeching halt when
Hulk took over at the end of the movie and
flew the Quinjet into space.
The third era began when Hulk showed up two
years later in Thor: Ragnarok, beginning a
three-movie character arc.
This new story continued as Hulk remained
out of sight throughout most of Infinity War.
The end of the three-part story will take
place in Endgame, with some sort of climactic
event likely in store for the Jade Giant.
Black Widow has proven to be an absolutely
invaluable addition to the team over the years.
She first appeared in Iron Man 2, already
trained as an accomplished spy and assassin
working for S.H.I.E.L.D.
She showed up again in Avengers and played
a critical role in ending the Battle of New
York when she closed the portal with Loki's
Scepter.
She went on from there to help topple HYDRA's
infiltration of S.H.I.E.L.D and bring Ultron
down in Sokovia.
She turned heads yet again when she switched
sides to join Team Cap in Civil War, helping
Captain America and Bucky Barnes escape in
the Quinjet.
She re-emerged with Cap and company in the
early minutes of Infinity War and made her
presence known throughout the fight in Wakanda.
Black Widow has been featured heavily in the
Endgame trailers and seems likely to be right
by Cap's side when the action picks up again.
Thor has enraptured fans since the moment
Mjolnir was seen in the end credits scene
of Iron Man 2.
The Son of Odin kicked things off on a low
note in Thor by being sent into exile after
he disobeyed his father.
However, by the end of the movie, he had grown
into a character that appreciated the seriousness
of his responsibilities as a prince of Asgard.
After his opening film, he provided some serious
muscle for the Avengers in the Battle of New
York.
He then flew off to stop the Dark Elf Malekith
from wiping out the entire universe in his
second solo adventure.
From there he doubled back to Earth, where
he helped stop Ultron and conducted some preliminary
Infinity Stone research.
However, the character truly hit his stride
in Thor: Ragnarok.
The humor-infused capstone to Thor's trilogy
brought a whole new angle to the Asgardian
as he struggled with the loss of his father,
took down his sister, and ultimately took
up his kingship.
The movie also set the stage for Infinity
War, which opened with many of the surviving
Asgardians being wiped out by Thanos.
During Infinity War, Thor's character arc
reached an electrifying conclusion as he forged
Stormbreaker, summoned the Bifrost on his
own, and even managed to land what looked
like a fatal blow against Thanos.
It's no understatement to say that the King
of Asgard enters Endgame ready for a rematch.
Much like Natasha Romanoff, Clint Barton has
made an MCU living off cameos and supporting
roles, and his lack of superpowers naturally
puts him at a disadvantage.
But that's never done much to stop the arrow-wielding
hero from making his mark.
Hawkeye made his first appearance in Thor
as an agent of S.H.I.E.L.D.
He showed up again in Avengers, when Loki
possessed him with the Mind Stone.
Once he was freed from the Asgardian's influence,
however, he was quick to join the Avengers
in their successful defense of New York City.
From there, his path led to Age of Ultron,
when he brought the refugee Avengers to his
family's home.
The revelation that Barton was, at heart,
a family man brought a new dimension to the
character.
After the mess in Sokovia, Barton retired
from the Avengers only to be drawn back into
the fray by Cap during Civil War.
The whole affair ended with him under house
arrest.
During the scene at the Avengers HQ in Infinity
War, Black Widow reminded the Avengers, and
the audience, about his current legal status:
"Where's Clint?"
"After the whole accords situation, he and
Scott took a deal.
It was too tough on their families, they're
on house arrest."
While he may have sat out for the first half
of the two-part epic, the trailers for Endgame
have revealed that chances are good we'll
see quite a bit more Barton, this time likely
under the guise of Ronin.
While it may seem hard to believe, Steve Rogers
was the last of the big six to make his entrance
into the MCU.
His first solo movie, coming right before
Avengers, traced Rogers' path from a rejected
military recruit to the super soldier Captain
America.
After stopping Red Skull in his origin film,
Cap went on to save the world again in Avengers,
becoming the heart and soul of the superhero
team.
Next, Cap teamed up with Black Widow and Sam
Wilson, a.k.a. Falcon, to take down a HYDRA-infiltrated
S.H.I.E.L.D. in Captain America: Winter Soldier.
From there he led the Avengers into their
battle against Ultron in the second Avengers
installment.
In Civil War, he chose to defend Bucky Barnes,
put his shield through Iron Man's chest armor,
and was forced to go into hiding.
He re-emerged from exile in Infinity War after
being informed of Thanos' imminent arrival.
There's no doubt that Cap is more than capable
of holding his own in a fight.
But, much like Tony Stark, his true journey
so far has revolved around his inner struggles.
Over time he's shifted from a shining beacon
of national hope to a fugitive on the run
from the very government that created him.
No matter how bad things have gotten, Steve
Rogers has never lost his ability to follow
his moral compass, a fact that will certainly
play into his decisions in Endgame.
While the six founding Avengers have all had
their own personal story arcs throughout the
first three phases of the MCU, the story of
their alliance as a team of Earth's mightiest
heroes has also played a prominent role
in the lead-up to Endgame.
Thanks to Captain Marvel, we now know that
Nick Fury was given the idea to create the
"Protector Initiative" in the mid-'90s after
seeing how real the threat of an intergalactic
invasion could be.
Of course, he fittingly renamed it the "Avengers
Initiative," creating the famous name for
the superhero squad, after he saw that it
was Danvers' call sign in the Air Force.
The first Avengers featured Director Fury
as he assembled the Avengers to face the threat
of Loki and the Mind Stone.
Sure, the team had a few early issues, but
you can't gather that many eccentrically powerful
personalities into a single group without
expecting some kind of friction.
Besides, who doesn't want to watch Thor take
on the Hulk in a helicarrier?
But after getting over those growing pains,
they meshed together beautifully as they took
on Loki, bottled up the Chitauri hordes in
NYC, and sent a nuke as a parting gift before
closing up the invasion portal.
As the credits rolled, the team looked good
enough to eat.
Y'know, like, at a table:
Almost an entire phase after the first Avengers
movie, its sequel, Avengers: Age of Ultron,
arrived in theaters.
The Battle of New York spooked Tony Stark
enough to begin working on what he called
the Ultron Program, which was meant to protect
the world from future global threats.
Of course, the whole experiment went horribly
wrong when they introduced the Mind Stone
to the equation, inadvertently creating Ultron
in the process.
Age of Ultron provided an opportunity for
the team to grow, while also introducing classic
Silver Age characters Scarlet Witch and Vision.
Both characters have become Avenger staples
since, and are even getting their own miniseries.
Ultron also served as a launchpad for Thanos
and the Infinity Stones to move toward center
stage.
After their high point in Avengers, the next
chapter of the group's history would be shadowed
by internal friction.
As if Ultron wasn't bad enough, just a couple
of movies later the Avengers turned on each
other in Captain America: Civil War.
With Hulk and Thor both out of the picture,
the third installment of Cap's trilogy saw
the rest of the gang fall out hard after an
operation went south, leading to civilian
casualties and a public relations nightmare.
The event sparked the demand for the Avengers
to sign the Sokovia Accords, which were designed
to provide a measure of government control
over superpowered vigilantes.
Split over whether to sign the Accords or
not, Tony Stark and Steve Rogers rallied the
Avengers into two separate groups before duking
it out during the famous airport battle in
Leipzig.
The story ended with Rogers and company on
the lam, with the rest of the Avengers either
technically operating under government control
or under house arrest.
Needless to say, it was a low point for the
team.
The next time the entire team was seen in
action was when Thanos showed up, and the
results were anything but pretty.
Infinity War began with the Mad Titan and
his minions embarking on their quest for the
Infinity Stones in earnest, and for much of
the movie, the Avengers were scattered across
the galaxy, all fighting to the best of their
ability on their own.
While several team members were able to provide
a united front in Wakanda, and Iron Man and
Spider-Man were able to team up with Doctor
Strange and the Guardians of the Galaxy on
Titan, Thanos ended up having relatively minimal
trouble getting through each of the groups
separately.
As the Infinity War credits rolled, Tony Stark
was stranded on the other side of the solar
system, with the remaining Avengers wallowing
in the dust back on Earth.
The questions that remain going forward are
if, how, and when the team will finally reassemble,
for the first time since the end of Phase
2, to take on Thanos with a finally united
front.
In an interview with Empire Magazine, Marvel
boss Kevin Feige explained just how important
Endgame is as a capstone for the entire first
three phases of the MCU.
He explained:
"We wanted to bring to a conclusion a series
of movies in a way that had never been done
before.
Harry Potter had an ending because there were
only so many books.
Lord of the Rings too.
But we thought, 22 movies in, wouldn't it
be fun to bring some finality to the storyline?"
The knowledge that the creators themselves
see Endgame as a sort of capstone for the
first three phases of Marvel movies is reason
enough to expect that the Avengers, particularly
the central six that have been so focused
on so far, will play critical roles.
The fact that they were all left standing,
along the heavy focus on them in the promotional
material for Endgame, seems to imply that
the "Infinity Saga" that started with the
founding Avengers will end with them as well.
While the Infinity Saga may be drawing to
a close, the sky's the limit for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as the studio moves forward
from Endgame.
At this point, a whole new batch of potential
Avenger material is available in the form
of newer characters like Spider-Man, Black
Panther, and the newest member of them all,
Captain Marvel.
In addition, there's the boatload of A-list
Marvel characters brought into the fold thanks
to the Disney/Fox merger.
The point is, Marvel has a lot to work with,
and the abundance of options opens up the
possibility for Endgame to be more than a
long-awaited reunion of old friends saving
the world yet again.
While it's sad to think of going into Phase
4 without all of the original Avengers around,
there's no doubt that their influence will
continue to be felt for years to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.